[Musica]
la fotografia è uno di quelle passioni
che ho sempre avuto ma che non sapevo di
avere quelle passioni passive no che tu
hai da tutta la vita senza però
accorgertene o rendersene conto
finché un giorno non te ne rendi conto e
dc giusto
ho un amore molto specifico per
qualsiasi tipo di immagine immortalata
in pellicola a questa qua e sono io al
tecnico di mio padre perché mio padre
architetto tutta sfocata sarà perché
senza di loro non esisterebbe il
cinematografo
oppure perché hanno un fascino le
fotografie quasi mistico per me è
l'essere immortalati è diventata una
parte della nostra vita talmente passiva
che ci dimentichiamo ogni tanto che può
essere una forma d'arte e non solo per
dire è il sono riuscito a fare una color
correction decente ma non so cosa
farmene quindi ve la faccio vedere senza
un motivo specifico questo che vedete
sono io quando ero molto molto piccolo
fotografato nelle posizioni più
disparate dalla mi sto annoiando a morte
alla roberto bolle questa è una foto con
mia sorella questa è una foto con i miei
genitori ma la maggior parte delle volte
sono sempre stato ripreso da solo e in
un modo o nell'altro sono sempre stato
circondato dall arte della fotografia ho
sputato tutto uno dei libri fotografici
più belli che io abbia mai visto e che
abbia mai avuto è stato inferno questo
libro di fotografie drammatiche guerre e
di fame veramente veramente angoscianti
ma incredibilmente affascinante
io sono uno di quelli che si ferma
spesso in quegli articoli online del
tipo 20 fotografie che raccontano la
pandemia 20 fotografie che raccontano la
guerra in kosovo 20 fotografie che
raccontano l'undici settembre ed è
sempre roba che sta morendo non è mai 20
fotografie di mia mamma che fa la torta
al limone non mai
tali poi un attimo cadere ed arrivare ad
uno dei miei fotografi preferiti steve
mccurry che ha fatto del immortalare in
un singolo frame determinati periodi
storici e momenti di vita la sua vita ed
essendo appunto una di quelle cose che
ti porti dietro da tutta la tua vita ma
senza rendersene conto
non ho mai pensato realmente di farla un
po come quando ascolti musica o guardi
un film non penseresti mai dici vabbè
adesso provo a diventare cantanto prova
a diventare regista o attore e lì ma non
lo fai realmente anche su youtube uno
dei miei youtuber preferiti in assoluto
e peter mcelhone 1 youtube fotografo lui
oltre ad avergli insegnato
indirettamente un sacco di fotografia
bianche fatto scoprire qual è lo stile
che mi piace la street photography non
solo che tipo di fotografie ma anche
come post produrle in modo super iper
pacchiano io sono una persona pacchiana
ormai me ne sono reso conto se non
faccio tutte le cose in modo flash uso
non sono contento è così che funziona lo
scoperto denunciatemi per farvi capire
se dovessi consigliarvi un film la prima
cosa che mi viene in mente uno degli
ultimi che ho visto è stato 1917 un
capolavoro a livello di narrazione a
livello di fotografia a livello di
colori a livello di tutto però se
dovessi realmente dirvi qual è un film
che mi ha emozionato di più di 1917 e mi
ha fatto provare più emozioni
diversificate durante la visione sarebbe
fast and furious 8
per quanto mi riguarda fast and furious
8 è molto più emozionante di 1917 non
vuol dire che sia un film più bello
nella maniera più assoluta non vuol dire
questo ma effettivamente mi ha fatto
emozionare di più perché non ho mai
provato così tanta adrenalina come
vedere
[Musica]
il 1917 non c'è questa cosa qui è un po
mi dispiace però quindi sapendo cosa ti
piacerebbe provare e sapendo come mi
piacerebbe provarlo perché non farlo
perché non uscire dalla mia cazzo di
confort sean hayes riuscire a fare un
pochino di street photography c'è sempre
un cazzo di motivo per non fare qualcosa
sempre soprattutto quando è un cervello
di merda che ti mette paletti
inesistenti in ogni singola cosa che
cazzo se ne frega
l'ha detto cartier bresson le prime 10
mila fotografie sono le peggiori se l'ha
detto un fotografo professionista ci
sarà un ulivo la prima fase
ovviamente è stata la camminata
fotografica prendersi un po di tempo per
camminare e fare fotografie in mezzo
alla strada
una delle cose che mi frenava di più e
la vergogna del fare fotografie
io ancora adesso non riesco a capire
come facciano ad essere così sfacciati
tra virgolette da fare foto ad eventi
che dove non riusciresti neanche a
guardare tanto meno tira nessuna una
macchina fotografica e immortalare il
momento
ma esattamente una di quelle cose lì che
dovrei riuscire a togliere dalla destra
quindi per questo motivo qua quasi per
non essere da solo o attaccata una
telecamerina al petto e vi ho portato
insieme a me una delle cose fondamentali
da capire quale attrezzatura portale ho
letto libri ho seguito youtuber ho visto
un miliardo di milioni di corsi in
questa settimana per capire quale
sarebbe l'attrezzatura migliore la
risposta è più o meno tutto ho scoperto
di avere una fotocamera e delle lenti
ottime per fare le fotografie
la fotocamera è la sony alpha 6400 il
problema più grande però è quale
obiettivo usare una cosa su cui tutti
erano è d'accordo è utilizzare un
obiettivo a focale fissa ai o in 16 mm
grandangolo però il grandangolo secondo
me non è così intimo nelle fotografie
quindi optato per l'altro obiettivo
fisso il 50 mm e posso già anticiparvi
che per metà ha fatto un lavoro egregio
per l'altra metà è stato un incubo
e adesso non ho più scuse l'attrezzatura
cielo la vergogna cerco di togliermelo e
parto per un'ora e mezza di camminata
[Musica]
sotto la pioggia che per certi versi è
stato molto affascinante molto molto
meno per altri in tutto ha fatto 140
foto di cui non salvate una quarantina
una cosa che ho cercato di togliere
facendo queste 140 fotografie sono tutte
quelle quegli errori che la gente che
non si mai approcciata a questo
argomento fa costantemente e si possono
tutte quante di assumere con una singola
frase fotografie alla luna ogni volta
che c'è una luna rossa una luna piena
la gente con l'occhio nudo la vede
perfettamente poi tira fuori il
cellulare fa la fotografia ed è un
puntino luminoso in lontananza e piano
dicendo che quello è un errore che ho
imparato dalle altre persone che ho
scartato
l'altro è quello di fotografare ad
altezza occhi ogni volta che vidi un
qualcosa il tuo cervello percepisce che
potrebbe essere artisticamente valido da
incorniciare in una fotografia
la fotocamera si tiene sempre ad altezza
occhi e tutte le foto sono tutte uguali
l'una all'altra e tu dici ha però nella
mia testa era un pò meglio perchè questo
è un altro insegnamento che ho imparato
dai grandi fotografi della storia è che
il tuo corpo deve essere macchina
fotografica tanto quanto la tua macchina
fotografica ma prima di farmi vedere le
foto che ho fatto
si passa alla fase due la post
produzione e per questa occasione ho
imparato utilizzare lightroom quello per
pc l'ho comprato ho visto un sacco di
corsi e suggerimenti ed e ho imparato ad
usarlo e non solo per fare la color
correction ma anche per imparare la
composizione di una fotografia
perché non ho parlato della regola dei
terzi della spirale eccetera eccetera
perché saremo discorso anche fuori dalle
mie competenze ma ho imparato anche a
fare un pò quello anche rompendo la
regola di terzi molti fotografi
consigliano per la color correction di
partire da un presepe di qualcuno e poi
da lì modificare tutte le statistiche
io invece devo dire ho fatto il
contrario ho creato un mio presente che
è tilen donan fatevene una ragione ho
fatto un presenti land orange perché a
me piace quello va bene osmin chiato
tutti i colori delle fotografie
per farle un pro cinematografiche però
potete scaricarlo gratuitamente lo metto
in descrizione così
volendo potete partire da luglio
presenze volete sono partito da un luogo
al chiuso anche per fare qualche foto di
interni ma ne ho fatta se soltanto una
perfettamente simmetrica e devo dire che
mi piace molto perché sembra riflesso di
quasi acqua passando poi per il pont
olimpionico sono riuscito a fare un
miracolo con un 50 mm così stretto
prendere l'intero pon del con l'intero
arco è un signore che io ringrazierò per
tutta la vita per avere una manica dello
stesso colore dell'arco poi mi sono
girata 1 scattata un angolo con un po di
gente l'eliporto devo dire che torino e
it hyland orange per natura
io ho modificato le foto non così tanto
come sembrerebbe ecco poi più urban
fotografi di questa foto con i graffiti
sullo sfondo lo genoa mi piace molto mi
piace molto camminando per un parco poi
beh con un signore seduto da solo sulla
panchina e ho tentato di fare una
fotografia in stile mister robot lui
completamente a sinistra girato a
sinistra quasi sbagliando appunto la
composizione però non lo so mi dava un
effetto quasi rilassante passando poi
vicino ad un mucchio di macerie ho detto
a perché non fotografare però fare una
foto alle macerie era anche brutto
quindi ho aspettato che passasse un
signore perfettamente al centro e ho
scattato la fotografia
io nella fotografia adoro le foto delle
persone in cammino
quindi lo fate un sacco il problema è
che se sbagli le tempistiche non sembra
che la persona stia camminando ma sembra
che stia sembra un robot che non abbia
ancora imparato bene come camminata poi
ho iniziato a settorializzare le
fotografie
qui ce ne sono un pochino con le persone
un po di di vita
qualche coda alla farmacia a causa della
pandemia un po di anzianità al bar visto
che adesso hanno riaperto
un'altra cosa che adoro e fotografare
l'interno dei negozi la gente che ci
lavora dentro ma appunto per la vergogna
molto spesso non lo facciano quindi ho
fotografato un negozio con un cartello
stradale all'interno qualche graffito
ecco questo signore spiega perfettamente
il problema
per fotografare in modo sbagliato le
persone cammino sembra che stia per
precipitare in un lago sembra che si
stia per buttare in acqua perchè l'ho
fotografato quando stava mettendo il
piede in avanti invece che sollevare
quello dietro qui c'è la foto di quello
che pensavo fosse un bagno pubblico
invece è un distributore dell'acqua
perdoni signorina qualcuno che si
protegge dalla pioggia a volte più
simmetrico a volte meno simmetrico
purtroppo non sono mai riuscito a fare
delle fotografie frontali alle persone
perché non ne vedo il motivo io ho paura
che si mettano anche vergogna che mi
dicono ma che stai facendo non lo fare
io perché gli dico poi salve sono gen un
esperimento voler partecipare un
esperimento di uno youtuber qualsiasi
quindi ho una marea di foto di persone
di spalle a piedi in bici in monopattino
e queste sono già quelle tipo più
corrette perché si vede il piede dietro
alzarsi invece che quello davanti al
davanti un po di fotografie che
piacciono tanto all'estero quelle terza
moreno pizza pied d'amore con la testa e
la signora questa property metterla in
qualsiasi periodo storico andrebbe bene
torino è la città per eccellenza dei
cani ci sono centinaia di migliaia di
cani con padroni ovunque ma purtroppo la
sfortuna vuole che piovendo ce ne
fossero veramente veramente pochi questo
è il primo che ho fotografato con tanto
di occhiataccia della proprietaria e
l'altra è una coppia che con il cane
stava andando chissà dove chissà fare
cosa
chissà perché una delle mie foto
preferite è questa questo ragazzo che fa
l'elemosina davanti a un carrefour è
stato quasi mio vicino di casa per tanti
anni quando abitavo in quella zona ed è
proprio in questa fotografia qua che mi
sono messo la più grande vergogna ma mi
sono accorto dopo che sono andato a fare
la post produzione
questi due signori che mi squadrano
indicandomi come se stessi facendo
chissà cosa durante la fotografia ma ero
in piedi con la macchina fotografica lo
giuro dove lo stavo facendo niente lo
potete vedere anche voi
fortunatamente non li ho visti facendo
la fotografia però guardando il filmato
del top che il caso camminando poco più
avanti mi accorgo dire
mi giro all'improvviso e scatta una
fotografia di how i met your mother
senza dire che aumenti ormai ed ecco qua
però perché mi piace molto intanto
dietro quei coloni c'è una banca che è
tutta vetrata io ho detto porca miseria
o l'occasione di fare una foto riflessa
sui vetri vedo una ragazza con un
ombrello rosa aspetto per tipo un minuto
buono che passasse da li faccio la
fotografia ed ovviamente ho sbagliato e
sta alzando il piede davanti e sembra
che stia capendo ci ho provato però in
compenso ho fatto una fotografia più
tumblr che io abbia mai fatto una foto a
me stesso coperto in viso d'angelo e
proprio all'ultimo poco prima di tornare
a casa
sono riuscito a fare finalmente la
fotografia ad una persona durante un
momento di quotidianità all'interno di
una panetteria e devo dire che è venuta
splendida è sì ho fatto una foto anche a
cupido tornando a casa
sì eccolo qua l'unica foto che non vi ho
fatto vedere è la mia preferita in
assoluto non è niente di incredibile non
è una foto in un paese del terzo mondo
nella foto di guerra in afghanistan è
una semplice foto street di una ragazza
che sta camminando
mi piace la composizione mi piacciono i
colori ho azzeccato il tempismo infatti
le linee del piede e le vie di fuga di
questa fotografia sono secondo me ottime
e guardandola mi lascia un senso di pace
quasi perché ti fa fare un po quelle
domande che sicuramente anche apprezzare
anche a voi saranno capitate camminando
per strada guardando una persona
specifica dicendo chissà chi è doveva
chi sa che lavoro a casa che vita ha
fatto quando era piccolo
non so mi dà mi dà quella sensazione ed
è stato veramente tanto l'altro diverso
da fare è l'ultimo step che ho voluto
aggiungere ma che purtroppo non ha
portato così tanto è lo step 3 creare un
account
ad hoc di street photography mio per
vedere se sarebbe riuscito ad arrivare
da qualche parte
la risposta è ci vuole un anno
probabilmente per portare un account di
fotografia da zero a mille
sono contento però che tutte quella
decina di like che sono riuscito ad
avere sono di altri fotografi quindi che
dire di questa esperienza che è stato
incredibile questo per dirvi che a parte
la fotografia molto probabilmente c'è
qualcosa qualche passione che è rimasta
incastrata dentro di voi ma non riuscite
a rendervene conto
provate ad aprire gli occhi del vostro
cervello e di tanto perché magari
potrebbe uscire qualcosa che non vi
aspettereste mai a questa qui volevo
vedere io chi mi ha fatto questo foto
quali ci sono io qui in basso a sinistra
è praticamente il soggetto principale la
panda e i signori dietro tipo e side
story e io e questo è successo